cuz we are right hi guys welcome to
Friday rave write diary if you don't
know it's a look back at my weekend vlog
form my week started off with a collab
shoot hi Friday I know I'm not going to
a PTA meeting I'm coming to a shoot how
I ended up like this I don't know
exactly I look like a cop's wife we're
headed to the opposite side of town to
shoot with Rosanna pansino nerdy nummies
we're doing an episode of it I'm so
excited I don't know if I'm allowed to
tell you what we're making we're making
pizza cake I might have to censor that
because I'm not sure that that's allowed
to be exposed but you know what blood be
exposed this fashion sense I'm running
like five or ten minutes late because
traffic also I just have no sense of
time I assume I can get everywhere in 20
minutes and grace it's not true future
grace that's editing this video and
listening to present grace you cannot
get everywhere in 20 minutes stop trying
also stop trying to look like your head
of your neighborhood watch look I got
this from this human look at this okay I
can show them what we made today yes
okay I see then this is insane we made
this and I mean this yes whoa does that
say wait here boils pizza cake and death
big the videos going to come out soon
and you guys will learn how to make it
it's actually very very easy to make
also another spoiler alert uh Rosana you
are four foot ten yes oh my god this is
so good
she's a petite little thing but packs a
lot of flavor you guys she gave me this
gift bag of amazing treats is so
exciting also with the other most
exciting facet of your company and home
oh my god are these creatures look at
this thing this is cookie oh my Irene
look at I the Internet hi guys
yeah did you hear that the internet just
broke and speaking of amazing faces look
at this beauty King right here Henry
Henry you don't know right then you have
no idea how much joy you bring people
just by existing
and then there was the Teen Choice
Awards hello fry diary it is Sunday
right now and I'm prepping for the Teen
Choice Awards yeah when DJ Diaz is here
but this is a manifestation of when DJ
Diaz at all of her beauty things to make
me beautiful she's already started doing
this and if you could see her though she
is she's prepping some more beauty
things it takes a village of one
extensions are going back in like old
buddies except not as long as before but
man they look real
Oh
legacy is important especially when
you've done terrible things and then I
got to see Lindsey Stirling if you don't
know oh my god get your life together
in concert she's amazing violinist
dancer performer singer just wonderful
human being
you
the show was absolutely amazing and
unfortunately it was the end of her tour
so you can't see her life anymore but I
went online and watched a bunch of the
videos of her other tour dates before
seeing the show so you can go online and
see all kinds of videos from the show
and it's really kind of so good it's so
inspiring then this happened
happy Tuesday Friday awry now this
sentence feels very weird to say but I
just had the easiest DMV experience I've
ever had in my life
cool Tuesday hi fry diary
happy Wednesday yeah I'm headed to go
shoot a video with Nikki limo yeah one
of my favorite people excited let's go
oh I realize didn't plug anything
collabing with Nikki limo but it went
really really amazingly and there's no
way no until the video comes out maybe
it's already out by now maybe it's not
if it is it'll be there if it's not
something else will be there oh my god
oh my god oh my god that's a really cool
Terminator impression you're doing right
oh yeah and then I had a lot of writing
to do which isn't fun to film for you so
obviously I procrastinated in my writing
by making a picture frame for a Van
Damme cartoon that I bought off of Etsy
yes and then this is something that
happened in cooking it's like soup and
salad and that Oh terrified okay and
then this happened good morning Friday
it's Friday morning and I'm drinking
coffee and we're watching bloodsport
because that's how we get the day
started out great way started a very
inspirational he beats him up while I'm
about to see okay he loves it who's a
huge jean-claude Van Damme fan I'm about
to see a very inspirational scene oh
it's happening okay bye and I was
probably afternoon and I'm going to edit
this all together so that you can see it
as you just saw it right now because
tonight Hannah Hart and I are going to
the Taylor Swift concert I know
and Karlie Kloss started following me on
Twitter this morning so something in the
universe is happening and I just feel
like I might be in her entourage after
tonight
remember to hydrate kids I don't know
also don't forget Alif you haven't
already leave a thumbs up if you enjoyed
these kind of videos and follow me on
all the social media platforms at grace
Helbig except on snapchat it's real
grace Helbig because someone else took
that snapchat name saddest fear comes
creeping in okay bye